and I agree with that I think and I rank
what the block I think goes right to
your leadership and that's LeBron James
and tyloo obviously this team is stage
ready
hurry ready and connect civil lead is up
to 17 or up to 7
24:17 hurry find some room gets off the
three got it
[Applause]
finishing so far in this first half
got himself an easy one there not yet
curry hips appraise Steph Curry from
downtown probably defense will you say I
did a good jump misses step curry the
rebound helping out he's a terrific
guard rebounder curry again Tucsonans
steph curry drills another three and the
lead balloons to 15 against offensive
rebounding extra possessions curry
answers right back curry back in the
corner nice little fake sets up another
Scott it again the curry back-to-back
threes Green pass too low veturi
recovers shot clock winding down so he's
gonna have to put it up launches it up
shot clock down
hurry with the shot clock expiring Steph
Curry Hanlon recognized the clock is
dwindling down it actually looked
beautiful in the end my goodness mama
there goes that met early finds green
back to curry three-quarter putts
coming up on three and a half remaining
his golden state curry way outside
another three Steph Curry has set a
Finals record his night three-pointer of
the game but he is in fine form right
now
[Applause]